[Music]
I turn my camera on I cut my fingers on
the
[Music]
way so hello everybody um I am a postto
in the Alice feere research group at UC
Santa Barbara um I'm going to be talking
today about live coding and live coding
performances using a browser based
environment I created called
uh but first a little more about the the
lovely Campus of UCSB if you ever have a
chance to come to Santa Barbara uh it's
a great place to visit and hang out
maybe not the best place to get a degree
cuz you're less than half a mile away
from the beach at all time but uh a very
nice place and I work in a virtual
reality facility a scientific instrument
down there called the allosphere and
this is the allosphere from the top
looking down into it it's a three-story
sphere um enclosed inside of a cube with
a bridge mounted in the horizontal and
vertical center of the sphere and we
have 26 projectors inside of the sphere
that cover the entire surface of the
sphere with scientific simulations and
data visualizations and that's actually
the director of the allosphere um Joanne
Cera Moren standing on the bridge um
right there the surface of the sphere is
actually perforated with tons of tiny
tiny holes and when you have light
shining on the outside of the sphere it
basically makes it look like it's
transparent but when those lights are
turned off and you're on the inside of
the sphere it really looks like uh an
opaque opaque surface um so this is
actually a fractal synthesizer made uh
by the man in the foreground right there
Kenny Kim and it's it's a 3D fractal
synthesizer you notice that people are
wearing glasses in the sphere right
there and this content is not static
content he's parameterized it so that
it's animated and evolving over time
uh so here's another shot with basically
taking the the outside of the Moon and
then kind of mapped it to be um on the
inside of the sphere and this is looking
from one end of the bridge down towards
the the other end you can accommodate
about 30 people on the bridge of the
allosphere at a time which makes it
ideal for doing uh collaborative
knowledge Discovery inside of there so
instead of just having you know VR
environments where it's just one person
inside of it this has really been set up
so you have this giant screen that lots
of people can take advantage of
simultaneously for doing types of
research but today I'm going to come
back to the alere at the very end of my
talk but today mostly what I'm going to
be talking about is um live coding live
coding performance creative coding again
using an environment um that I actually
created called gibber that runs in the
browser and is made completely uh with
JavaScript uh but first a little bit
about live coding uh performance it
means live coding means something a
little bit different in the the Digital
Arts community so it's not just getting
up and doing a demo of coding something
for a conference or whatnot it's
actually getting up on stage plugging
your laptop into a projector and
speakers and coding a work of
audiovisual art while projecting your
code for the audience members to follow
along with so it's kind of a
experimental performance practice um
it's particularly popular um in Europe
especially but uh also in parts of Latin
America as well so
the interesting thing about this is that
um we're introducing transparency into
the performance process so it's not just
me or somebody else standing up here as
a DJ kind of dancing around and moving
things every once in a while but you and
the audience don't really have any idea
what we're doing I could just be
checking my Twitter account and playing
a
CD by actually projecting the code as
I'm typing it you're actually able to
see me create the algorithms modify
those algorithms over time and maybe get
some type of insight into what the
processes are that are actually
happening in the
performance and this is some of the the
live coding Manifesto taken from a
website topl lop.org if you get
interested or inspired by any of this
this is the place to go to get
information about all things live coding
and there's a couple of interesting
quotes in this but one of the ones I
find most interesting is this one right
here and that says it is not necessary
for a lay audience to understand the
code to appreciate it much is not
necessary to know how to play a guitar
in order to appreciate watching a guitar
performance so even if I'm coding to a
room of people that are not JavaScript
experts uh not the situation today which
is really exciting for me actually um
there there's still hopefully some type
of insight that the audience can get
just by watching the code appear seeing
when I execute the code and and seeing
how that manipulates the audiovisual
content on the
screen
so there's a bunch of different types of
live coding environments and languages
out there and this is by no means a
comprehensive list there there are
dozens of them um and I just put a
couple of Representative examples up
here and one thing I wanted to point out
with these examples is that a lot of
them use domain specific examples so we
can see a bunch of them here where the
developers have actually gone and
created their own language for doing
these types of performances and that's a
really nice thing for the developers to
be able to do because it gives them the
opportunity for them to encode creative
affordances directly into the syntax of
the language so you can make an operator
that maybe chains two types of audio
effects together or you could make
another operator that takes two
three-dimensional objects in a scene
graph and makes their rotations track
one another and having domain specific
language opens up all those different
types of opportunities but at the same
time well actually getting ahead of
myself a little bit let's take a look at
what a couple of those languages look
like
so this is a um a system called iyang
and it's used to live code music
performances and in it we can basically
see um this piano module that's that's
being live coded and I'm creating a
piano instance right here and then I'm
sequencing notes of a scale to be played
at different moments in time basically
the the uh the moment in time that these
notes get played is based on where they
fall inside of these staple brackets
right here and down here I see a
stringed instrument that I sequencing
and and some drums different sounds can
all be compiled inside of ixil Lang and
one of the first live coding
performances I ever saw was actually an
XY Lang performance it's a really really
fun environment um here's another one um
Live code lab that is also a
browser-based environment like jber so
if you have a chance to Google Live Cod
lab it'll pop right up and it's a domain
specific language that's used to control
3js so you can basically create
three-dimensional objects rotate those
objects apply different types of effects
and you see the syntax um is is fairly
simple to to use and it it's um been
used to teach kids and also in use in
live coding performances as
well but as I started getting more and
more interested in live coding I was
interested in the potential of
JavaScript for a live coding environment
because JavaScript although it's it's
it's a fairly flexible expressive and
and dynamic language it's also general
purpose I mean we've we've heard people
um at this conference that have used it
for all sorts of different purposes
whether it's client side server side use
in Adobe products scripting the unity
game engine there's all sorts of
applications that expose a JavaScript
API for developers to use so by working
on a live coding platform that uses the
general purpose language uh we can
ensure that the knowledge gained while
learning to program in these
environments transfers to all of these
other systems so jbra uh my environment
is a browser-based creative coding
environment it provides Audio Visual and
interactive affordances and one of the
the research areas for me is trying to
figure out unified ways to approach both
audio and visual programming um it uses
JavaScript as the end user language and
there's also a server where users can
upload the sketches that they make um
they're stored in a a couchdb database
it's a it's a node backend um and
there's also a websocket based chat room
and you can click on a user's name
inside the chat room and instantly start
a collaborative code editing session um
using the share. JS
Library so let's take a look at what
that looks like um so this is jber It's
just running at jer. matat uh that's the
Media Arts and Technology Program at UC
Santa barbara.
edu and um we see a coding area over on
the the right hand side here and on the
left is a browser uh where you can see a
variety of different demos that that
show different examples of things a
bunch of different tutorials that
explain um the basic programming
Concepts in Jibber I mentioned that
there's a database backend where users
can publish their files so you can
search that database for maybe you want
to see how to do drum programming or
maybe you want to see how to do 3D
Graphics programming uh and then files
that you as a user have individually
published and recent files that have
been published using the system but
let's take a look at the actual coding
that's done inside of gibber um so I'm
going to start out uh the hello world
for audio programming in gibber is just
to make uh drum
beat I appear to not have internet
connection oh I have very slow internet
connection okay so there's the the drum
beat that's going and this is basically
a simple pattern pattern here where X's
are the kick drums O's are snare drums
and because there's four characters in
this pattern gibber automatically makes
each one of those be a quarter note in
duration if I go ahead and add some
symbols here I can rerun that line of
code and just change the jump read and
now since there's eight characters it
makes each one of those values into an
eighth note instead of a quarter note
and so I can just keep kind of going and
playing around with different values see
what happens here um if I want to assign
a specific value for the tempo I can do
that right here so now they're all 16th
notes now they're 64th
notes um
[Music]
yeah um so that's that's a drum beat in
Jibber and one of the things that's kind
of interested that you might have
noticed is that I as I go and I've been
running this line of code over and over
and over again um there's only one drum
beat that's playing at any moment in
time so one of the things that I found
that's kind of interesting in Jibber is
that it's actually nice to be able to
just iterate calls to the constructors
to create these objects so that now I
don't have to go back in and then change
the values of the notes to be something
else and then change the values of the
durations to be something else instead
of doing that I can just manipulate this
same section of code and just run it
over and over again and it'll just
replace the drum beat that was already
there so I'm doing that by using Getters
and Setters on all the single letter
variable names in the global namespace
so when I do my performance at the end
you'll see that I use a lot of single
letter variable names and that's the
reason for it whenever I store something
in a single letter variable um the next
time I try to assign something to it
Jibber goes in and it checks and sees if
there's already an audio visual object
in that variable and if there is it goes
and it removes it from the audio visual
graph and replaces it with the new
object um that I've created and this
works for both the audio elements and
also for the graphical elements as well
as I'll demo in a second so let's go in
now and make a a a synthesizer and just
get some examples of how to play
notes so here I'm saying play the note C
in the fourth octave and there's the
note C in the fifth octave now I can
pass those values as a string but I can
also pass numbers right here and if I
pass the number
zero what that does is there's a there's
basically a default scale inside of
gibber and zero says select the first
note of that default scale and the the
default scale happens to be C minor in
the fourth octave so as I change
this you hear it just kind of works its
way up the scale SC so I mentioned one
of the uh nice abstractions for gibber
that it's inside of here is this ability
to kind of keep iterating calls to
Constructors another one is the ability
to schedule changes to properties and
schedule calls to methods over time very
easily so note is a method of my synth
object to sequence multiple calls to
this all I do is I add a do
seek and then I give it an array of
values that I want to sequence and then
just like the drum beat I give it a
duration for how long I want each note
to
[Music]
last and then I can change this to
alternate here between eighth notes and
quarter
notes oh I cleared it okay I
yeah
[Music]
and I can start the drums back up with
it and then I can also go in and I can
tell it to randomly select from these
arrays every time it triggers a note so
here just by adding this R&D to the end
of the re
array uh now it's going to randomly
pick both the value and the duration
that's used right there
and I can do that also with properties
so the drums have a property called
[Music]
pitch
so now it's randomly changing the pitch
uh on every drum beat that since sound's
getting really annoying so I'm G to I'm
G to sorry I let that go on a little too
long um but I'll stop that there and uh
I guess the last thing I'll point out
with the audio before I move on to the
graphics is that it's also really easy
to add um
[Music]
effects
um yeah so you can add effects to the
drums you can add effects to the syns
there's a bunch of different types of
syns available inside of gibber and
there's a lot of predefined sounds that
make it easy to start kind of just
combining sounds really quickly so let's
look at the graphics so with Graphics um
there's two different modes of Graphics
in gibber one is is wrapping 3js and the
other mode is wrapping canvas and I
guess there's actually a third that kind
of combines
the two together which I'll explain in a
second but here I can see I can just
make a cube um I can tell that Cube to
spin um and I again just like with the
drums I can just keep changing the
values and re-executing it and because
I'm using that single letter variable
name I only have one Cube that actually
appears on the screen at any moment in
time
oops
and the sequencing also works the same
way so I can take the scale and I can
sequence changes to it just like I
sequenced changes to the audio earlier
so here I'll sequence changes every 250
milliseconds um to the scale of the cube
that's right there and we had audio
effects that we looked at earlier um but
there's also different types of visual
effects let's change it to a different
geometry um and let's do a a
collidoscope
Shader um and we can change parameters
of the Kaleidoscope for how it's doing
and again we can sequence this so any
property of any audiovisual object you
can just immediately start sequencing
things um either lining it up with the
musical Rhythm or just giving it
arbitrary millisecond values um to make
changes over
time so one of the the last abstraction
that I'm going to kind of talk about
before I show a couple of of of demos
and then go over to some of more the
technology behind all this is an
abstraction that allows you to to easily
do mappings and it's actually kind of a
way of doing a sort of reactive
programming I I would say so if I make a
drum uh drum set right here and now I
make a
cube um I can go in and I can say Okay I
want the scale of my Cube to track the
output put envelope of my
drums and it immediately starts doing
that and I can do that with any property
of any audiovisual property it also
works the other way I could have the
pitch of the drum track the rotation of
my Cube as it goes around or I can do
things like um let's make this a little
easier to here I can set the pitch to
track the
mouse
and again with the cube I could have
that track the mouse on the x
[Music]
axis and basically the the the trick
here is to capitalize the the name of
the property that you want to make the
mapping between on the right hand side
of the assignment operator and that's
the cue to to jibber that you want to
set up this kind of reactive programming
link between the two properties and do a
continu ous mapping between the two
values as opposed to just taking the
instantaneous value at the moment in
time when you execute the
code so let's look at some of the
different demos that are inside of here
um first I'll start off this is a a
[Music]
demo um so that's that's the whole code
for this um so we've got some music
that's being sequenced right there and
then I'm creating a 2d canvas object
overriding the draw method to create
these color bars that are displaying um
the fft analysis that's being performed
inside of there so here's an example
um and I can make this a little easier
to see full screen um this is an example
using a a flocking algorithm um where
each one of the the tetrahedrons is an
agent that's kind of attracted to U the
icosahedron you see that they're kind of
following around and the audio um each
one of the agents is downloading a sound
from the freesound.org database if you
haven't checked out freesound.org is a
great place to find audio files and
basically I'm querying for audio files
that are tagged with the word laughter
and I'm asking to randomly pick one of
those files and then as the agents move
up and down the speed of the sample
playback changes which in effect changes
the pitch of the
samples
so we could go in here and I could
change
this following the the Cat theme that
seems to be present in every
conference so it's downloading the
samples right now
[Music]
we evil
cats
okay
um so here's a quick example that shows
getting the the webcam and I think the
the cool thing about this is just that
it it you know it doesn't take very many
lines of code to do this right I have a
cube I tell it is there still a cat
screaming yeah there is okay whatever I
I'll fix that in a second so there's a
video on the cube um I'm spinning it
I've applied a couple of different
post-processing shaders to this uh so a
half tone Shader that's generating that
kind of dots effect and the film Shader
that's that's doing this kind of uh
basically doing the color gradient right
there okay now I'm going to really stop
the cats um here's an example of a mouse
Trail because every browser braced
creative coding tool has to have a mouse
Trail in it um and one of the cool
things I mentioned earlier is that you
can combine 2D drawing in gibber with um
3D which doesn't really make a lot of
sense but let me just uh show it right
here so I've got a 2d canvas that I've
placed onto the screen that I'm drawing
to and it's tracking my mouse position
but now if I go and I say b equals
Kaleidoscope I get this crazy effect so
I've actually taken a WB GL Shader and
I've applied it to the 2D canvas so what
happens is when you first start drawing
in 2D in gibber you create a canvas
object gibber goes in and it places a a
regular canvas object onto the page and
creates a 2d drawing context in there if
at any point after that you create a
Shader object like this Kaleidoscope
Shader gibber then goes and hides the
original 2D canvas creates a 3D canvas
and places it on the stage and then uses
the the drawings on the 2D canvas that
are now hidden to texture a full screen
open GL quad and that enables you to be
able to do this type of Shader
processing on type of the 2D drawing so
that's really nice especially for
beginning programmers because maybe all
they can do at the very beginning is
draw some squares kind of bouncing
around but if you suddenly pop a bunch
of different shaders and start playing
around with those you can get a lot of
visual complexity uh without having to
do a lot of
coding okay I think that's it for those
demos so let's go back to the
slides okay
so there we go so how does how does this
all kind of work um this is kind of the
different libraries that make up gibber
um all the libraries are available both
on GitHub and on npm so the main gibber
environment up at the top here wraps a
library called gibber doli that you can
actually include inside of any normal
HTML page you can basically just put it
in a script tag and then you can write
normal uh gibber code inside of your
page and there's also an option to not
globalize everything I'm sure you've
noticed that everything is in the global
namespace in gibber so if you want to
have everything popularly named space
that's an option you can pass to the
initialization method and then there's
three primary libraries that that get
wrapped in gibber one's an audio library
one's a graphics library and one's an
interface library for creating goys to
control the different audio visual
objects inside of Jibber um since the
graphics Library basically wraps 3js in
the canvas and I'm sure most people in
here have experience with those I'm not
going to talk about uh that a lot um
except to say it you know it makes
things a little bit easier instead of
having to set up a camera and having to
Define lights and having to deal with
all those different aspects you can just
say a equals Cube and something pops up
and then as you get more advanced with
your programming you can learn about the
how the camera works and manipulate
those properties then but this lets you
get something up on the screen to play
with as quickly as possible but what I
did want to talk about today was the
audio library and in particular um this
gibberish. JS because I think that's an
interesting thing for um might be an
interesting thing for JavaScript script
developers uh to to look
at so um this is the website for gibber
it's just Charlie roberts.com sorry
gibberish Charlie roberts.com
jibberish and basically what gibberish
does um so the web audio API provides a
a audio system for defining all of your
audio Digital Signal processing using
JavaScript um and that's what this
particular Library gibberish actually
does um the problem with doing that is
that every one of your audio nodes in in
the graph that you create is you know
it's a function that's being called
44,100 times per second in a typical
typical digital audio setting so you
have to create very optimized audio
functions in able to be in order to be
able to do that consistently without
causing lots of crackles and crashes in
your audio
engine uh and that can be a tricky thing
to do so what gibberish does is it
provides an objectoriented notation for
people to Define these audio graphs and
then takes the the graph that you define
and flattens it into a series of
function calls that that get executed
and this can be executed much more
efficiently than on every sample 44,000
100 times per second trying to
recursively recursively resolve all the
dependencies of the various audio
objects so let's do a simple example
right here um here's a vibr that modul
Ates over time and the code on the left
is the code that you would actually
write as a developer using this Library
where I'm basically making a couple of
different sine waves I'm saying I'm
setting the amp of one sine wave to be
whatever the output of another sine wave
is and then I'm creating a third sine
wave that's basically taking mod one
adding whatever the value of that is on
each sample to
440 um and then connecting that to the
master output bus so so you hear this
vibr that gradually gets wider and wider
over time um as these sways kind of
fluctuate in and out in relationship to
one another over here is the Callback
function that gibberish actually creates
so it's basically just a function that
accepts a bunch of other functions and
then those functions get called um one
after another and the most of the data
that the function actually needs in
order to uh execute is is inlined into
the function argument so in that way we
avoid if there's object dependencies we
avoid having to kind of resolve those
dependencies because of course there's a
there's overhead associated with that in
Dynamic runtime environments here we're
putting those directly inside in line
into the function calls so here's the
first sine wave it gets stored in this
variable that variable is then placed
inlined into the second sine wave which
gets passed in there and then that gets
inlined into the third sine W that
generated is generated which then gets
fed into the master
bus so this enables um some different
types of signal processing than most
JavaScript audio libraries are capable
of doing because you can process every
single sample in here one at a time most
audio processing libraries that use this
JavaScript node uh for generating audio
process things in blocks of 64 samples
at once so you take each sine wave and
you do 64 samples and then you pass all
64 samples into the next sine wave and
then that goes into the next sine wave
and the problem with that is that you
it's very difficult to do sample
accurate scheduling with timing um
you're basically limited to time there's
hacks you can kind of do to work around
it but you're you're kind of limited to
um timing that's in blocks of 64 samples
or more so a little bit more um than a
millisecond and the bigger problem is
that you can't do feedback networks so
you can't take the output of one
oscillator and have it feed back into
itself to create different different
types of feedback because there there's
no way to do that you have to go through
the entire 64 samples before you can get
the output and feed it back into the
input again so here's just a quick
example of a feedback loop um inside of
Jibber so this is the kind of a map of
of the routing that we see up here where
I've got this synth it's feeding into a
bus it's feeding into a filter it's Fe
feeding into a single sample delay unit
so there's a one sample delay and then
the sample goes back into the the bus
and creates a loop um and likewise down
here the master output is also feeding a
single sample delay which then goes back
into this bus and if you look inside the
code we see these calls to single sample
delay they those return the last sample
that's been stored and these ones at the
end here um record the last generated
sample for use in the next iteration
so there's a bunch of different sounds
that come with gibberish um here's like
a an emulation of a classic drum machine
uh classic analog drum machine from the
the
80s
um here's a that synth here's some
string
sounds more
[Applause]
syn different types of
effects and so all of this stuff gets
wrapped up um and used inside of
Jibber but of course you don't you don't
really have to deal with that low-l code
the other thing that jibber audio lib
and Jibber add to gibberish is uh
knowledge of Music Theory so you can
Define scales it knows what a quarter
note is all of those things so you can
immediately start making music with it
instead of having to create those
systems
yourself and this also
runs inside of uh node so uh you can you
can just npm install jabber. audiolib
and then this is the
[Music]
test maybe not your traditional mocha or
Jasmine test but um it it it works
uh and yeah so you can use this code
inside of any HTML page you can use it
inside of nodejs and you can use it
inside of the gibber environment
itself the other thing that um I've done
is taken that how many people have heard
of P five. JS
anybody one person okay how many people
have heard of
processing.js okay a little bit better
so processing is a creative coding
environment for Java
processing.js is a very clever hack that
takes the Java code used in processing
and compiles it into JavaScript p5.js is
a new version um of the the processing
API that's written from the ground up in
JavaScript so it's not trying to do
packs to like compile JavaScript it's
really written um from start to finish
with the idea of of using JavaScript in
mind so you can use
um gibber with P5 there's a library
called
[Music]
p5.js code that you see where there's a
setup method where you you set up your
canvas and do all those things and then
a draw method where you actually draw to
the canvas so there's also some inter
oper interoperability with other
environments built into to
gibber okay so um in using Jibber it's
been used a lot in universities um both
to teach entire classes I have a
colleague Ryan McGee who's teaching a
class in the art department at UCSB
where he's teaching artists about sound
and then as they move through and learn
more and more about sound how to match
sound up with visuals and and create
visual music systems um it's also been
used in a couple of different ways by
Louisiana State University so this is a
a performance um where they're all
running gibber on their laptops um
creating a networked music piece and if
you see here over here on the right side
I mentioned earlier that there's a
websocket based chat system they're
using that chat system to communicate
with one another um during the actual
performance and they've also at
Louisiana State University um in the
electronic music and digital media um
research group that's actually led by
this guy right here Jesse Allison
they've also led a series of summer
camps for both Middle School girls which
is the one we're looking at right here
and also for high school students where
the students start off learning a little
bit of basic JavaScript in gibber and
then slowly advance to building their
own musical instruments that run inside
of the browser um and they also use a
really interesting framework for
Designing goys for audio visual
performance called Nexus UI if anybody's
interested in wants to check that out
it's a really powerful system for
Designing interfaces for this type of
performance
practice and in terms of Education um
the thing I I'm interested in going back
to the allosphere that I discussed in
the beginning is what could happen if we
bring kids into the allosphere we
surround them with this 3D content they
put on their glasses stuff's flying past
their faces there's sounds moving around
everywhere and then we say okay now
we're going to let you guys go out and
go back to your houses or go back to
your schools and spend a few weeks or a
couple of months um programming things
inside of gibber and when you created
something that you like upload that into
gibber's database then you can come back
to the allosphere with your friends and
your family and play it for them inside
of this immersive environment and so the
challenge for me in my research going
forward is going to be thinking about
how to scale up from this single browser
window to 26 warped and Blended
projectors and 56 channels of of audio
um which I'm I'm really looking forward
to it's going to be it's going to be
really
interesting okay so I've got 10 minutes
left but a little bit more than that and
I want to leave time for at least a
couple of questions so I'm going to
maybe do like a seven minute performance
something like that um uh typically when
I perform that it's it's longer um
usually anywhere from maybe 15 minutes
to I think the longest I've ever pulled
off has been a full hour um
um and what else did I want to say about
that oh I also wanted to say if you're
interested um there are these events
called Alor Raves that happens and an
algorave is basically when a bunch of
live coders get together and audience
members at a club and live coders get up
on stage and they do their performances
and supposedly people dance to these
this type of of Music it it kind of
winds up being a lot of head nodding and
then every once in a while somebody will
just go crazy for reasons that nobody
actually knows um but keep an eye out
for algo coming to an area near you soon
uh it's just algor rave.com if you want
to learn more about
that so I'm just going to reload Jibber
so I can kind of start with a blank
slate
[Music]
for
dead
president dead dead president
de
president de
president
de presid
[Music]
de
dead
president dead
president
presid dead
dead Dead
Presidents
dead president dead
president dead de president dead
president Dead
[Music]
Presidents
president
dead president
dead
[Music]
you
sh
[Music]
w
thanks and there's still three and a
half minutes for questions left yes yes
but um oh wow I have I have absolutely
no words to describe this but we should
definitely have some questions I'm sure
they are burning questions in the minds
of many musicians and engineers and
developers right here designers like
seriously you combined audio visual
coding everything together
questions yeah want to I think we are
still breathing in and breathing out
yes trying to digest um it was that was
like amazing really like I don't know it
was trippy um but anyway
um is there a way for gibber to you know
um connect multiple computers and sync
up the BPM so you know like couple
computers can work you know can
collaborate on the same thing together
at the same time yeah I haven't
implemented that as of yet but I'm I'm
really interested in that and there's
been some some cool work with that based
on work that's been done in the video
game in you know industry in terms of
like syncing firstperson Shooters and
the events that have happened in there
um so so uh people have done that
research but I haven't I haven't had the
chance to kind of stick it into gibber
yet so like um right now the only option
for uh multiple computers to work on
gibber together is to actually sync up
the BPM manually is that correct well
you don't have to do dance music you
could have it be ambient and textures or
um you know some person could program
Graphics while one person works on a
beat and another person could randomly
play different talking samples I guess
they the the the copout answer is you
don't have to do things that are beat
synchronized um but but yeah it would be
it would be really nice if if I had that
in there and like I said the research
has been done I just need to get around
to to putting it in there all right
thank you awesome stuff thanks
Gabe so this reminded me of uh a lot of
music that I've listened to over the
years I'm wondering who are your musical
influences oh uh top fe uh I mean like
ones that come off off the top of my
head they don't have anything to do with
this type of music unfortunately like uh
Stevie
Wonder um Keith Jarrett um actually
there's an amazing live coding
performance if you have a chance uh look
up live coding and Keith Jarrett the a
very talented live coder named Andrew
Sorenson does a just beautiful
performance where he recreates the piano
style of Keith Jarrett who was a famous
jazz pianist who played with Miles Davis
and led lots of famous trios over the
years and it's it's it's really
incredible
um yeah sorry I don't have better
answers that that influence like this
style of music I mean I like a lot of of
like dance music that also involves
acoustic instruments so one thing I'm
interested in is trying to do more gigs
uh playing with live musicians um that's
something I hope I can do more of in the
future thank you thank you Charlie
Roberts for that awesome performance and
mind-blowing us
could we take
uh do we have time for one or okay just
one more question maybe all right yeah
wow that that was impressive I just
wonder me uh this currently bit sits
inside a browser and and in nodejs does
it currently uh integrate with like
Hardware or any
software that works jish right now J not
gibberish uh yeah so you can read the
mic input uh into gibber and record that
as a sample and then process it uh
however you want just like I was
processing the the samples from the free
sound database and in the performance
they do actually have apis for talking
with um audio interfaces like fire wire
and USB audio interfaces I haven't
really explored too much of that um yet
but it's out there cool so it doesn't do
any midi in out there is midi in and out
actually have that is like a separate
you can download a module that does that
from the the central database and yeah
I've got some demos of that and if you
write me an email I can send you a link
to those demos cool thank
you thank
you